[Music]
we're here with bloom farms and we have
some trinkets that you can smoke we here
my man my somebody we live in a time
right now we're portable vaporizers are
in everybody's pocket why not add some
style add some fashion add some class to
it for every product that we sell we
donate a meal to one of seven food banks
in California Nevada
well we've donated about 1.2 million
meals over the past few years really we
just try to bring awareness to it
so that you can make it positive impact
and I'm think you guys are doing a great
job you know you got some of this for
the host of the show a couple of these
to take with me couple of these and
y'all are doing good this year
I'll tell you the truth the first one
right here this is our high THC version
we call this highlighter Plus this is
about a 80% or more THC right next to it
is our rose gold highlighter
that's pretty it's pretty right yeah
it's beautiful it's a it's a one-to-one
CBD to THC ratio and then on the right
side here we've got our highlighter
uncrate special edition we only made a
few thousand of these things a nice
matte soft touch finish it's also a
one-to-one CBD THC ratio
[Music]
that's clean
give me some pricing so these are right
around $100 a piece well I guess the
show is the most expensive it's right
sighs I'll pull up here how many how
many how many pumps in this thing uh
well it depends on how big a puffy take
yeah so this is the most expensive is
tech break and this would actually be
smart the great way to check